Enfin c'est ce qu'on lit dans les journaux, non?
Donc je veux savoir qui sont tous ces gens sur ce forum.
Alors oui, tu peux aller sur le forum,
mais seulement si chacun y utilise son vrai nom,
et fournit une copie complète de son casier judiciaire.
Mais bien sûr, si qui que ce soit dans le forum demandait son vrai nom,
je dirais: « Non, tu ne peux pas le donner. »
Car qu'arrive-t-il s'il s'avère que sont des pervers,
ou des profs ou que sais-je.
Vous avez donc ce paradoxe bizarre
où je suis content qu'il aille dans ce forum
si je sais qui d'autre y est,
mais je refuse que quiconque sache qui il est.
C'est comme une impasse autour de l'identité:
on réclame une totale transparence de tous,
sauf de soi-même.
Alors on n'avance pas,
on est coincés.
Le forum est donc imparfait
et c'est une très mauvaise façon de réfléchir à l'identité.
Alors sur mon fil RSS, j'ai lu cette chose à propos -
je viens de critiquer mon fil RSS, non?
Je ne devrais plus le dire ainsi.
Pour une raison qui me dépasse
tout ce qui parle de majorettes atterrit dans ma boite mail.
Et j'ai lu cette histoire captivante
sur le sujet.
Il y a quelques années aux États-Unis,
un groupe de majorettes d'une université,
elles ont dit des choses méchantes
sur leur entraîneur,
comme tous les enfants critiquent leurs profs
à mon avis,
et l'entraîneur a fini par le découvrir.
Elle était très vexée.
Elle a alors dit à l'une des filles:
« Tu dois me donner ton mot de passe Facebook. »
Je lis ça constamment, même dans des universités
des lieux d'éducation,
des enfants sont forcés de donner leur mot de passe Facebook.
Ils n'ont pas le choix.
C'était une enfant!
Elle aurait dû dire:
« Mon avocat vous appellera
demain à la 1ère heure.
C'est une atteinte au 4e amendement sur le droit à la vie privée.
Ça va vous ruiner
en indemnités. »
Mais c'est juste une enfant,
et elle a donné son mot de passe.
La prof n'a pas pu se connecter sur Facebook,
car l'école en a bloqué l'accès.
Elle devait donc attendre d'être rentrée chez elle.
La fille l'a dit à ses amies,
et que se passa-t-il?
Les filles se sont connectées à Facebook sur leurs téléphones,
et ont effacé leurs comptes.
Donc quand la prof s'est connectée, il n'y avait plus rien.
Mon propos est, ces identités, ils n'y pensent pas de cette manière.
L'identité est, surtout quand vous êtes un ado, une notion souple.
Vous avez des tas d'identités.
Si l'une d'elles vous déplaît
car elle a été détournée, n'est plus sûre ou ne convient plus,
vous la supprimez simplement et en créez une nouvelle.
L'idée que votre identité vous est donnée par quelqu'un,
gouvernement ou autre,
et que vous devez la subir et l'utiliser en tous lieux,
est totalement fausse.
Pourquoi vouloir vraiment savoir qui est qui sur Facebook,
à moins d'avoir de mauvaises intentions?
Et cela ne fonctionne pas correctement.
Et mon 4e exemple est qu'il y a des cas
où vous voulez vraiment être -
Au cas où vous vous demandez, il s'agit de moi à la manifestation anti G20.
Je n'y étais pas vraiment, mais j'avais une réunion dans une banque,
le jour de la manifestation et j'ai reçu un e-mail de la banque
disant: « Ne portez pas de costume SVP car cela va exciter les manifestants. »
J'ai belle allure en costume, franchement,
vous comprenez que je produise chez eux
une fureur anti-capitaliste.
(Rires)
J'ai donc pensé, bien
si je ne veux pas exciter les manifestants,
à l'évidence,
je dois leur ressembler.
Je me suis donc habillé entièrement en noir,
vous savez, avec une cagoule noire,
des gants noirs,
que j'ai retiré pour signer à l'entrée.
(Rires)
Je portais un pantalon noir, des bottes noires...
J'entre dans la banque à 10 heures,
« Bonjour, je suis Dave Birch,
j'ai un rendez-vous avec etc... »
Bien sûr. Signez ici.
Et j'ai mon badge visiteur.
(Rires)
Donc ce non-sens
qui vous oblige à donner votre vrai nom sur Facebook ou autre
amène à ce genre de sécurité.
Cela donne une sécurité de façade, où il n'y en a pas vraiment,
mais les gens jouent plutôt un rôle dans une pièce sur la sécurité.
Si chacun apprend son texte,
tout le monde est content.
Mais ce n'est pas une véritable sécurité.
D'autant que je déteste plus les banques que les manifestants du G20,
car je travaille pour elles.
Je sais que les choses sont en fait pires que ce qu'ils imaginent.
(Rires)
Mais imaginez que je travaille à côté de quelqu'un dans une banque
qui était en train de faire quelque chose.
Comment appelle-t-on ces gens qui volent l'argent dans les banques... Trader!
Imaginez que je sois assis à côté d'un trader escroc,
et je veuille le signaler au directeur.
Je me connecte pour l'alerter.
J'envoie un message, ce type est un trader escroc.
Ce message est dénué de sens
si vous ne savez pas que je suis un trader à la banque.
Si ce message vient de n'importe qui,
il n'a aucune valeur informative.
Envoyer ce message n'a pas de sens.
Mais si je dois prouver qui je suis,
je n'enverrai jamais ce message.
C'est comme l'infirmière à l'hôpital signalant le chirurgien ivre.
Ce message n'existera que si je reste anonyme.
Donc le système doit fournir des moyens de garantir l'anonymat,
sinon nous n'irons pas au bout.
Donc 4 problèmes. Alors, qu'allons-nous faire à ce propos?
Eh bien, nous avons tendance à
penser à la manière d'Orwell.
Et nous essayons de créer des versions électroniques
de la carte d'identité dont nous nous sommes débarrassés en 1953.
Nous pensons donc qu'avoir une carte,
mettons un identifiant Facebook,
prouvant notre identité,
en permanence sur nous,
est la solution.
Bien sûr, pour toutes ces raisons,
c'est faux, et cela pourrait
même empirer les choses.
Plus vous devez utiliser votre véritable identité,
particulièrement en termes de transactions,
plus elle risque d'être volée et dévoyée.
Le but est d'empêcher les gens d'utiliser l'identité
dans des transactions
qui ne la nécessitent pas
ce qui est le cas de la plupart des transactions.
Dans la plupart de vos transactions,
on ne demande pas: « Qui êtes-vous? »,
mais: « Ok vous avez le droit de conduire la voiture,
vous êtes autorisé à entrer,
vous avez plus de 18 ans,
etc. etc...
Donc je propose - je pense,
comme James, qu'il devrait y avoir une recrudescence de l'intérêt en R&D.
Je pense que c'est soluble,
que nous pouvons le régler.
Bien sûr, dans ces circonstances,
je m'en remets au Dr. Who.
Car sur ce point,
comme dans tant d'autres,
Dr. Who nous a déjà montré la réponse.
Je dois préciser,
pour certains de nos visiteurs étrangers,
que Dr. Who est le plus grand scientifique vivant, en Angleterre.
(Rires)
et un phare de vérité et d'illumination pour nous tous.
Voici donc Dr. Who avec son papier psychique.
Allez! Vous avez forcément vu le papier psychique de Dr. Who!
Vous n'êtes pas des geeks sinon.
Qui a déjà vu le papier psychique du Dr. Who?
Vous étiez peut-être en train d'étudier à la bibliothèque plutôt.
C'est ça?
Lorsqu'on montre le papier psychique du Dr Who
à quelqu'un,
la personne imagine voir
ce dont il a besoin.
Si je veux vous montrer un passeport britannique,
je vous présente le papier psychique,
et vous le voyez.
Je veux entrer dans une fête,
je tends le papier psychique,
et vous montre mon invitation.
Vous voyez ce que vous voulez voir.
Selon moi nous devons en créer une version électronique,
mais avec un tout petit changement,
c'est qu'on ne verra le passeport britannique
que si j'en possède réellement un.
Vous verrez une invitation
que si j'en ai vraiment une.
Ça ne vous dira que je suis majeur
que si j'ai vraiment plus de 18 ans.
Mais rien d'autre.
Donc, vous êtes le videur du bar,
vous avez besoin de savoir si j'ai plus de 18 ans
plutôt que mon permis de conduire,
indiquant que je sais conduire,
mon nom, mon adresse, ce genre d'informations
je vous montre mon papier psychique,
et ça vous dit si j'ai plus de 18 ans ou non.
Simplement.
N'est-ce qu'une chimère?
Bien sûr que non,
sinon je ne serais pas là.
Pour le créer et que ça marche,
- je vais juste le présenter sans trop de détails -
il nous faut un plan,
ainsi nous concevrons
une infrastructure accessible à tous,
pour résoudre tous ces problèmes.
Nous allons fabriquer un utilitaire,
qui doit être universel,
utilisable partout.
Voici un aperçu
de cette technologie,
Voilà un distributeur de billets japonais
l'empreinte digitale
est stockée dans le téléphone.
Pour retirer de l'argent,
vous posez le téléphone sur le distributeur.
et apposez votre doigt,
votre empreinte passe par le téléphone,
il confirme, c'est bien Untel,
et le distributeur délivre l'argent.
L'utilitaire doit être utilisable partout.
extrêmement pratique,
là c'est moi entrant dans un pub.
Tous les appareils sont autorisés
à l'entrée du bar.
Une personne de plus de 18 ans
peut entrer.
Et donc l'idée est, vous apposez votre carte d'identité sur la porte,
et si je suis autorisé, on voit ma photo,
sinon, ça affiche une croix rouge.
Et aucune autre information.
Il n'y a pas de gadgets particuliers.
Cela signifie une seule chose,
selon la déclaration de Ross,
et que j'approuve totalement.
Ce qui n' a pas besoin de gadget,
doit être dans le portable.
C'est notre seule option:
l'adapter aux téléphones mobiles.
Il y a 6,6 milliards
de forfaits mobiles,
- ma statistique préférée -
et seulement 4 milliards de brosses à dents dans le monde.
Cela a un sens,
je ne sais pas quoi.
(Rires)
Je compte sur nos futurologues pour m'éclairer.
Cet utilitaire doit être extensible.
Il faut
que tout le monde puisse
le faire évoluer.
Tout le monde doit pouvoir
utiliser cette infrastructure
sans autorisation, licence ou autre,
n'importe qui devrait pouvoir écrire du code autour de ça.
Vous connaissez la symétrie
pas besoin d'image.
Voilà ce que nous allons faire.
En utilisant les téléphones,
la proximité des mobiles.
Sachez que
la technologie derrière
le papier psychique du Dr. Who
est déjà là, et si l'un d'entre vous
possède l'une des nouvelles
cartes de crédit Barclay
avec le « sans contact »,
vous l'avez déjà.
Si vous êtes déjà allé dans la « grande ville »
et avez utilisé une carte Oyster,
cela ne vous rappelle rien?
Les 1ers téléphones
avec cette technologie,
le Nexus Google, le S2,
le Samsung Wifi 7.9,
les 1ers téléphones à avoir
cette technologie
sont déjà en vente.
Donc l'idée est que le préposé au gaz
sonne à la porte de ma mère,
lui montre son téléphone,
qu'elle tape sur le sien
et si un voyant vert apparaît, il est réellement de la compagnie du gaz
et elle lui ouvre.
S'il est rouge,
fin de l'histoire.
Nous avons la technologie pour faire ça.
Quoi d'autre?
Bien que certaines choses
semblent un peu contre-intuitives,
comme de prouver que j'ai plus de 18 ans
sans prouver qui je suis,
non seulement la cryptographie pour ça existe,
mais on la maîtrise.
Les signatures numériques, masquer les clés de certificats,
ces technologies circulent déjà,
nous savions juste pas comment
les incorporer.
La technologie existe déjà.
Nous savons que cela fonctionne,
Il y a quelques exemples de technologies
utilisées dans des endroits expérimentaux.
Voici la Fashion Week de Londres,
où nous avons conçu un système avec O2,
là c'est pour le Festival « Sans Fil » à Hyde Park,
on voit les gens
marchant avec leur bandeau VIP,
scanné et contrôlé
par le téléphone Nokia.
Tout cela pour vous montrer
que ce sont des choses prosaïques,
elles fonctionnent dans ces environnements.
Elles n'ont pas besoin d'être spéciales.
Donc, finalement, je sais que vous pouvez le faire,
car si vous avez vu l'épisode de Docteur Who,
le spécial Pâques,
où il est allé sur Mars en bus,
j'ajoute pour nos étudiants étrangers,
que cela n'arrive pas à tous les épisodes.
C'est un cas très particulier.
Donc, dans l'épisode où il va sur Mars dans un bus de Londres,
je ne peux vous montrer l'extrait,
en raison des restrictions scandaleuses de droits façon Reine Anne
de la BBC,
mais dans l'épisode où il va sur Mars en bus de Londres,
on voit nettement le Dr. Who montant dans le bus
avec le lecteur de carte Oyster
utilisant le papier psychique.
Ce qui prouve que le papier psychique
a un antivirus.
Merci beaucoup.